let's be frank about what this is all
about what this is really all about for
democrats
is political gamesmanship the new york
times essentially admitted
as much today when they acknowledge that
basically
democrats have a win-win scenario either
trump
is convicted in which case they get a
big victory not going to happen or
trump is not convicted in which case
they've had a chance for a couple of
weeks to beat up on republicans and in
the future they get to
to tie republicans in pr fashion to what
happened on january 6th so they think
well
there is one possibility that this
backfires and that is the longer that it
goes on the less the american people
seem to love it so here's what the polls
show right now according to the new york
times a majority of americans support
convicting trump
on an impeachment charge over his role
in the capital ride on january 6
only by a very slender margin according
to a range of recent polls
while there's broad agreement trump
deserves at least some blame for the
violence at the capitol the country
remains more closely split over whether
he deserves to be convicted by the
senate
in fact the views around this
impeachment trial aren't very different
from how things looked a year ago when
public opinion was tilted slightly in
favor of removing trump from office
during his first impeachment trial
democrats have since gained control of
the senate but they need a bunch of
republicans to vote with them
basically the split is 5644 in a cbs
news at yougov poll
56 of americans saying that trump should
be convicted 44 saying
he should be acquitted but there are
other polls that are way narrower
there's 12 percent of americans who said
they have no opinion on this and only 47
percent of americans saying they're in
favor of the impeachment 40 percent
opposed according to the ap
a q cupola quinnipiac university found
last week that 50
of americans said the senate should
convict trump 45 said that it should not
okay so bottom line is that americans
seem to be
pretty split on this particular issue uh
and
as time goes on and as it becomes
apparent that trump is no longer in
office
and as congress continues to basically
just posture
i think more and more americans are
going to say this is kind of a waste of
time that's the reason why chuck schumer
is rushing this thing forward
he had an interest in getting this thing
done fast right he wants a quick strike
pr hit gets to use this for the rest of
time to smear the republican party with
that is his goal here then of course he
says he's doing this in the name of
unity which of course is very very silly
here is chuck schumer
the the democratic senate majority
leader saying that um you know we can't
move on because
that's not going to bring unity yes
apparently only unity can be achieved
by trying to lump every republican in
with the january 6th riders which is
really what from a pr level from a comms
level communications level
that's what this trial is really all
about it's not about trump trump is a
background figure almost in this trial
at this point
here's chuck schumer saying
hypocritically that it's not going to
bring unity
to move beyond the trial listen i don't
think that unity is the highest value
i really don't but if your case is that
in order for us to achieve unity
we have to push forward with an
impeachment that half the country
doesn't support that's a weird way to
achieve unity
here is a here is chuck schumer those
who say let's move on
that brings unity are false when you had
such a serious
invasion of the capital
incited by
a president when you have such a serious
charge
sweeping it under the rug will not bring
unity it will keep the sore
open and the wounds open
okay so here is my favorite part of the
the constitutional argument being made
by democrats
so one of the things they are now
considering is blatantly
unconstitutional
if the impeachment trial fails one of
the things that they are currently
considering is the possibility of
invoking the 14th amendment
which could be done by pure majority
vote to bar trump from running for
office
ever again section 3 of the 14th
amendment allows congress to bar
individuals from holding office if they
have quote unquote engaged in
insurrection
they included that in the impeachment
charge itself but trump did not quote
unquote engage in insurrection he left
office as provided by law on january
20th
with no sort of official support
to bar him from office at this point
would be pretty obviously a
constitutional bill of attainer as ed
morrissey writes over at hot air
nothing in the language of the 14th
amendment confers authority on congress
to do anything except
waive a particular prohibition it
prohibits people who have committed
certain crimes from holding federal
office nothing in this denies these
people from having due process in a
court of law to make that determination
of guilt
in the first place because the fact of
the matter remains that you have to have
due process of law in order to
punish somebody this way congress is not
a court in any mode
other than impeachment democrats know it
by the way
right the fact is democrats know this
but they don't really care right
steve cohen is a democrat from tennessee
and he said
i know there's some concern about it
being a bill of attender i'm not
concerned about that because what he did
was horrific
and this is the way the democrats tend
to think i don't really care about the
constitutionality argument so
two things can be true once as very
often is true it can be constitutional
to hold an impeachment trial after a
person has left office
also the people who are arguing that
cannot care very much about the
constitution
that can certainly be a possibility did
you know that every like on this video
creates one additional leftist tier
don't ask me why that's called science
to take advantage of this amazing
opportunity
hit the like button